à l'adresse rt france points tv on se
quitte avec vos derniers mots rivier
mais ceci n'était pas un nouvel épisode
de walking dead mais pourtant on a parlé
de zombies tout le temps
[Musique]
la maison
hu
[Musique]
la nouvelle calédonie est choisi une
nouvelle fois de rester dans le giron
français mais le oui à l'indépendance
progress un vote d'autodétermination
marquée par une mobilisation sans
précédent
les partisans de la scission espère la
victoire lors du troisième référendum
dans deux ans théoriquement donald trump
pourrait sortir de l'hôpital dès demain
c'est ce qu'affirment ses médecins qui
ont donné une nouvelle conférence de
presse sur l'état de santé du président
américain
hospitalisé depuis vendredi donald trump
a eu des moments difficiles de la vue de
ces soignants mais aujourd'hui les deux
bouts dans un message la nuit dernière
le chef de l'état est sûr qu'il va
beaucoup mieux et qu'il sera bientôt de
retour dans la campagne présidentielle
la principale ville du nagorny karabach
visés par des frappes aériennes
8e jours de guerre entre l'azerbaïdjan
et cette région auto-proclamée
indépendante à majorité arménienne les
autorités indépendantistes affirme avoir
décrit un aéroport militaire en
azerbaïdjan dans la ville de gand déjà
sous le feu des forces arméniennes des
attaques condamné par la turquie
[Musique]
du
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france à la une
de l'actualité ce dimanche la nouvelle
calédonie reste finalement française
ainsi en ont décidé plus d'un électeur
sur deux dans cet archipel du pacifique
53,26 % en faveur du non à
l'indépendance il y a deux ans il était
un peu plus de 56 % à vouloir se
maintenir dans le giron de la france
des indépendantistes qui néanmoins
progresse il espère maintenant
l'emporter dans deux ans puisqu'un
troisième référendum ne sera
théoriquement organiser un scrutin
marqué en tout cas par une forte
participation près de 86%
un soulagement également pour le
président français les électeurs se sont
exprimés
ils ont majoritairement confirmé leur
souhait de maintenir la nouvelle
calédonie dans la france en tant que
chef de l'état j'accueille cette marque
de confiance dans la république avec un
profond sentiment de reconnaissance
j'accueille également ses résultats avec
humilité l'avenir c'est la dernière
étape de l'accord de nouméa
un troisième référendum est possible
c'est à vos élus du congrès de le
décider l'état
fidèle à sa parole se tient prêt à
l'organiser
si c'était leur choix des
indépendantistes qui regarde maintenant
vers 2022 il demande l'organisation de
ce troisième référendum comme prévu par
les accords de nouméa
un troisième scrutin contesté par les
loyalistes
vous voyez la réaction des partisans de
la sortie de l'archipel du giron
français
écoutez c'est une satisfaction pour nous
puisque la peau score c'est à dire
nombre de voix pour le oui alors que sa
peine soit et a nettement progressé
ce type de progression donc on en donne
les moyens
effectivement nous avons pas 50% comment
fixer comme objectif mais ce qu'on peut
retenir c'est que progression du oui est
clair et net tassement ya du nom le
prénom le glas corps de nos mains c'est
quand même trois rendez vous avec notre
histoire
donc du coup il faut avoir ça en tête
c'est qu'on a fait 2018 2020 et 2022
nous attendons donc ça veut dire que la
déception la garde juste pour ce soir
pour certains qui sont déçus ou qui sont
en train de pleurer mais demain le
soleil se lève et puis demain kanaky eh
ben elle a besoin de vous pour continuer
à faire son travail pour que le en 2022
et bien la pleine souveraineté de ce
pays elle soit effective il faut pas
baisser les bras pour apprentis avec un
déficit et qu'on a gagné tutoie tous à
leurs huit enfants ou en tête et ont
gelé ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui on va
dire maquereau ou à en faisant son
premier ministre et nous on va décider
aujourd'hui si on l'a sorti de notre
pays y compris aujourd'hui vous faudra
pleinement heureusement ça vous en dise
qu'il a bu un terrain aujourd'hui bas on
voit les difficultés et non la nouvelle
calédonie n'est pas française c'est ce
que pense alban bensaïd et anthropologue
et spécialiste de la nouvelle calédonie
la france une occasion ou plus humaniste
si vous voulez de rester dans pacific
avec les kanaks c'est de promouvoir ce
peuple a été colonisé qui devrait avoir
disparu si la colonisation était invité
à son terme et qui a relevé la tête à
parler de 1946 qui n'a cessé de de
s'intégrer à la calédonie et de proposer
des nouvelles solutions donc si l'on
prend en compte le peuple cocteau
détenus travaillent avec lui me à une
solution qui respecte que ses
aspirations ses valeurs et son apport à
la civilisation pensez-y sont importants
le actuel président du musée du quai
branly et est un kanak wallès kotra
était un kanak est dirigée pendant une
période
rfo et que je dépasse donc
les kanaks août à porter la nouvelle
calédonie et il faut que la france le
reconnaissent et leur fasse tout le
toute leur place en préparant il
souveraineté ouverte partager libéré
finalement qu'une autorité française qui
s'exerce dans des domaines où elles ne
devraient plus exercer et où le pays
s'ouvre un nouveau qui serait la cada
qui devait le cas est venu pour être
pleinement prendre sa mesure y compris
par exemple avec la france dans un
rapport renforcée avec les pays du
pacifique
la nouvelle ka et 2007 un pays du
pacifique ce n'est pas la france
aux etats unis le président américain
pourrait être de retour à la maison
blanche dès demain ses médecins en faire
un nouveau point presse sur son état de
santé aujourd'hui à donald trump qui est
toujours sous traitement aux rênes d
hiver depuis vendredi à l'hôpital
militaire de walter reed à washington
ces médecins qui ont admis des passages
plutôt grave ces dernières 48 heures le
président a bien venue des déficiences
respiratoires et de la fièvre
mais son état serait stabilisé selon ces
scientifiques il reste néanmoins sous
étroite surveillance
écoutez l'état clinique du patient
continue de s'améliorer
on ne présente plus de fièvre depuis
vendredi matin ses signes vitaux sont
stables
d'un point de vue pulmonaire ce matin il
est resté à l'air libre ne se plaint pas
d'essoufflement ou autre il se déplace
lui même se promène dans l'unité
médicale de la maison blanche sans
limitation ni handicape notre
surveillance continue de sa fonction
cardiaque hépatique et rénale montrent
des résultats normaux continue ou des
résultats améliorés
le président se sent bien il a marché un
peu aujourd'hui nous voulons le faire
manger et boire le faire se lever du lit
le plus souvent possible doit être
mobile
et si son état continue de s'améliorer
nous espérons prévoir un retour à la
maison blanche demain où il continuera à
son traitement de reprendre ses
fonctions il a envoyé un message vidéo
l'année dernière regarde finishing j'ai
hâte de finir la campagne comme elle a
commencé comme elle a été menée et avec
les mêmes chiffres qu'on a eu et dont on
est si fier mais c'est une chose qui
arrive et qui est arrivé à des millions
de personnes dans le monde et je me bats
pour elle pas juste aux états unis je me
bats pour est partout dans le monde
nous allons vaincre ce coronavirus ou
quel que soit le nom que vous voulez lui
donner regardez les thérapies celle que
je suis en ce moment et d'autres qui
vont émerger
elle ressemble franchement à des
miracles si vous voulez la vérité ce
sont des miracles les gens ne critique
quand je dis ça mais nous avons des
choses qui se produisent qui ressemble à
des miracles venue de dieu les combats
s'intensifient dans le haut-karabagh
entre les forces autonomistes arménienne
et l'armée azérie de nouvelles frappes
ont frappé ces dernières heures
stepanakert c'est la principale ville de
la région
1 malgré les appels à la trêve de la
communauté internationale vous le voyez
les deux camps ne dépose toujours pas
les armes et un bilan humain qui
s'alourdit au moins 240 personnes civils
et soldats tués de chaque côté depuis
huit jours maintenant
l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan qui est
soutenu par la turquie se disputent
cette région voyez ce qu'en dit le
premier ministre nikol pashinian il a
accusé la turquie le génocide nazi n'a
pas atteint itunes est leur objectif est
la destruction du peuple arménien pas
seulement des terroristes ils sont venus
pour continuer le génocide mythique
autre art à vos souris
nous devons briser le dos de l'ennemi
afin qu'ils ne posent plus jamais ses
mains criminelles sur notre terre
ne dirige plus jamais ces jeux sanglants
vers nous à lire notre article
j'aurais de l'ordinaire avec le conflit
un pli des mercenaires syrien des
terroristes des forces spéciales turques
et environ 150 militaires de haut rang
qui commande l'armée azerbaïdjanaise
dirigeant les opérations militaires
orapi le haut karabakh territoire ou
arménien et azéri s'affrontent depuis
maintenant une trentaine d'années la
tension qui est donc remonté d'un cran
cette semaine
rappel des faits avec emilie goog h les
combats ont commencé il ya déjà une
semaine dans la république autoproclamée
du haut karabagh une région dont la
capitale stepanakert est ensuite
bombardé par les forces azerbaïdjanaises
peuplé essentiellement d'arméniens le
haut karabagh a autoproclamé son
indépendance vis-à-vis de l'azerbaïdjan
en 1991 une indépendance que la région
compte bien défendre
la guerre va se terminer et bien sûr le
résultat de la guerre sera une défaite
et une perte pour l'azerbaïdjan et je
tiens à le dire haut et fort le haut
karabagh n'a jamais été conquis et ne le
sera jamais une émancipation que bakou
n'a jamais accepté
continuant de revendiquer sa
souveraineté sur le territoire
le premier ministre arménien nous a posé
des conditions
il y en a sept j'ai récemment déclaré
que nous rejetons de ces conditions nous
avons une seule condition le retrait
total inconditionnel et sans délai des
forces armées de l'arménie de notre
terre dans ce conflit
la région est reconnue comme étant
azerbaïdjanaise par la communauté
internationale bakou est également
soutenue par la turquie recep tayyip
erdogan n'a d'ailleurs pas manqué de le
rappeler cette semaine
un cessez le feu pérenne dans cette
région est tributaire d'un retrait
arménien de tout le territoire
azerbaïdjanais
la requête à présent dans cessez le feu
est inacceptable le président turc qui
est accusé d'avoir envoyé des
combattants djihadistes syrien à bas
coûts de leur côté les arméniens du haut
karabagh ont l'appui de la russie moscou
qui fait partie du groupe de minsk
aux côtés de la france et des états unis
créé en 1992 il est censé trouver une
solution pacifique au conflit
nous avons demandé un cessez-le-feu sans
condition en rappelant aussi à la raison
toutes celles et ceux qui parfois pouce
tel ou tel parti ahd et au delà du
raisonnable et nous allons tout mettre
en place pour arriver à une fin rapide
des conflits d'une part et reprendre le
chemin d'un réglement pacifique de ce
différend l'azerbaïdjan et la turquie
reproche au groupe de minsk d'avoir
laissé le conflit s'enliser durant 30
ans la flambée de violence dans le
haut-karabagh laisse craindre une
escalade des tensions dans la région
réunis en début de semaine le conseil de
sécurité de l'onu a demandé la fin
immédiate des combats au liban deux mois
après la double explosion qui a ravagé
le port de beyrouth faisant près de 190
morts et quelques 6000 blessés
l enquête se poursuit des experts
étrangers y contribuer vingt-cinq
personnes ont été arrêtées dont de hauts
responsables des autorités portuaires et
douanières
comment le liban gère-t-il la situation
alors qu'il est plongé depuis plusieurs
mois dans une crise politique sans
précédent ont fait le point avec
quelques hôtes eekhof
à cause de qui à cause de quoi la
catastrophe de beyrouth et ces
explosions titanesque semble être
l'aboutissement sous forme de métaphore
de la situation dans laquelle s'enlise
le liban depuis plusieurs mois et même
plusieurs années novembre 2013 les
autorités portuaires de beyrouth
saisissent une cargaison sur un bateau
battant pavillon moldave parti de
géorgie à destination du mozambique le
russe ce dernier avait accosté à
beyrouth en raison de problèmes
techniques selon le cabinet d'avocats
libanais baroux d'iéna sociales qui
représentent l'équipage du bateau les
autorités portuaires des charges d'alors
2007 150 tonnes de nitrate d'ammonium et
les stocks dans un entrepôt délabré aux
murs fissurés selon des responsables
libanais tandis que le rose us après le
lancement de poursuites contre le
propriétaire dont le nom reste inconnu
fini par couler au port de beyrouth en
2018 la suite
on la connaît selon une enquête menée
par l'ogc nice project un consortium de
journalistes d'investigation
le propriétaire du rose us seraient
charalambos manoli à magna du transport
maritime chypriote
ce dernier dément toujours toute
implication le capitaine du navire en
revanche avaient été identifiés presque
aussitôt après l'explosion et s'était
exprimé dans les médias
il s'agit d'un citoyen russe maurice
prokofiev selon lui il ne fait aucun
doute des autorités portuaires sont
corrompus les autorités de beyrouth
savait très bien qu'il s'agissait d'une
cargaison dangereuse il aurait fallu
l'évacuer
ils ont choisi de saisir le navire et sa
cargaison pour se faire de l'argent
évidemment mais s'ils avaient su qu'une
catastrophe arriverait il n'aurait
jamais fait cela
la cargaison était dangereuse elle
pouvait exploser à tout moment
il le savait autorités portuaires
corrompu donc mais encore dans une
longue tribune publiée dans le quotidien
libération
le chercheur et écrivain franco libanais
gilbert achcar explique que quelles que
soient les circonstances dans lesquelles
ces explosions soit survenu qu'elles
soient accidentelles délibéré qu'elle
provienne d'un premier incendie dans un
dépôt d'armement adjacent ou simplement
de feu d'artifice la responsabilité
d'avoir laissé 2007 150 tonnes de
nitrate d'ammonium hautement explosifs
entreposés au coeur d'une ville six
années durant à combat l'ensemble de la
classe dirigeante libanaise présidents
de la république premiers ministres
ministres des transports chefs des
principaux appareils de sécurité
administrateurs du port hesbollah tous
sont à blâmer dans cette catastrophe car
tous ont leur part de responsabilité
dans la manière dont le liban s'enlise
dans la corruption et la stagnation
politique
selon gilbert achcar il s'agit d'une
conséquence logique de l'histoire du
pays
marquée par l'effondrement de l'économie
libanaise cela fait 30 ans en effet que
le liban s'est engagée sur la voie de la
reconstruction après quinze années de
guerre civile et internationales et dans
un contexte mondial dominé par le
néolibéralisme et type avant 1975
l'année du début de la guerre le liban
était déjà réputé pour être un des
paradis fiscaux de la planète un pays de
capitalisme sauvage dont le secret
bancaire et les avantages fiscaux
faisait un terrain idéal pour le
blanchiment d'argent sale la fuite de
capitaux et toutes sortes de trafics
dans un environnement régional d'états
dictatoriaux fin septembre évaluer le
maquereau qui s'est érigée depuis deux
mois en grand médiateur de la question
libanaise
ce qui lui a offert un énième coup de
projecteur sur la scène internationale
alors qu'il est en difficulté dans son
propre pays affirmait j'ai honte pour
les dirigeants libanais et ce système de
corruption où tout le monde se tient
parce que tout le monde a touché
aujourd'hui quelques dizaines de
personnes sont en train de faire tomber
un pays dans le climat étouffant de
colère populaire au liban certains ont
pu espérer que ces double explosion en
entraînerait une autre politique cette
fois appuyée par une forte vocation
internationale organisation d'élections
sur la base d'une nouvelle loi
électorale formation d'un nouveau
gouvernement qui se libérait de l'
influence de la classe dirigeante
traditionnelle mais après l'échec
cuisant du premier ministre a formé un
nouveau gouvernement le liban s'enfonce
de plus en plus dans l'incertitude et la
division le port de beyrouth n'est plus
l explosion politique n'a pas eu lieu
et pour en parler nous sommes ce soir
avec michel fayyad analystes politiques
et financiers
bonsoir michel fayyad merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france il ya eu encore des
commémorations ce soir devant le port de
beyrouth
deux mois après cette explosion une
enquête internationale et est toujours
exclu le président michel aoun n'en veut
pas oui il n'y a pas d' enquête à
l'international et je pense pas qu'il y
en aura parce que comme l'a dit votre
reportage
en fait les différents partis se
tiennent vous avez d'un côté la
direction du port qui depuis 92 est
entre les mains du parti d'hariri le
ministère du transport qui puis 92 et
plus ou moins sous le contrôle du parti
de joe belote et la contrebande dans le
port qui est dans les mains du mouvement
amal du président la mairie du parlement
nabih berry et du hezbollah
donc chacun se tient et je pense que il
n'y aura pas il y aura pas vraiment un
résultat de la moindre enquête
oui mais même cette soi-disant en quête
intérieure aboutira selon vous à zéro
responsabilité
oui il y aura peut-être quelques
personnes qui seront sacrifiés mêlée
mais les partis qui ceux qui ont soutenu
ces personnes ne seront pas vraiment
inquiéter tant qu'elle dirige tant que
ces partis dirige le pouvoir le dirige
le pays est ce que finalement cette
explosion et cette enquête et à l'image
de ce que vit le pays aujourd'hui c'est
à dire une grave crise politique
justement à cause de la corruption et à
cause de cette classe politique qui veut
à tout prix se maintenir au pouvoir
oui tout à fait en fait on a vu une
initiative qui a été faite par le
président français yann macron et qui en
fait a été sabotée par différentes
choses la première étant que le club des
anciens premiers ministres composé de
quatre anciens communistes qui a voulu
nommer les ministres de toutes les
communautés
vous avez également le mouvement amal et
le hezbollah qui ont assisté à avoir le
ministère des finances
dans entre leurs mains parce que c'est
un ministère incontournable dans le pays
et vous avez également donc le président
le projet le premier ministre désigné
qui a voulu en fait contourner les
les prérogatives prévues
constitutionnelle entre pour le
président la république
donc tout ça ça fait que l'initiative
française a été sabotée par
essentiellement les partis sunnites et
les partis chiites c'est à dire les
partis qui sont représentés par le club
des anciens premiers ministres donc
hariri mikati et autres et les parties
civiles c'est-à-dire le mouvement amal
et le hezbollah
le principal défi aujourd'hui 10,1 à
bill berry le président du parlement
c'est de trouver le nom en tout cas de
trouver qui pour occuper ce poste de
premier ministre va qu'en maintenant
depuis plus d'une semaine
oui en fait le post communiste rêva camp
depuis même plus longtemps que ça depuis
quasiment l'explosion parce que le
gouvernement diab a démissionné à ce
moment-là et l'expédié actuellement les
affaires courantes
il est effectivement très important de
nommer un nouveau premier ministre et
qu'il formule un gouvernement le plus
rapidement possible parce que vous savez
aujourd'hui au liban
la banque centrale n'a plus de assez de
réserves en devises
les réserves en devises ne pourront
venir que disent que un mois un mois et
demi et vous savez avec ses réserves on
pouvait acheter du blé des médicaments
des produits pétroliers et après ça le
liban ne pourra plus le faire et déjà
vous avez monnaies qui est complètement
par terre vous avez un chômage au plus
haut vous avez là une chute du pouvoir
d'achat des libanais les des banques y
sont devenus des banques zombies et du
est en fait les libanais ne peuvent plus
utiliser leur argent librement et les
entreprises ne peuvent plus ouvrir des
lettres de crédit pour faire leur
travail
le pays est vraiment inter il faut
absolument un tout prix un gouvernement
le plus rapidement possible peu importe
qui seraient punis mais un gouvernement
tout de suite pour pouvoir négocier avec
le fmi
et obtenir le déblocage des fonds à la
fois du fmi et la conférence cèdre qui
s'était tenue à paris en 2018
donc ça c'est le plus important
aujourd'hui on sait que la jeunesse
libanaise a beaucoup annie festin avant
ces explosions
justement sur sur le pouvoir d'achat et
la catastrophe la crise économique dans
le pays et la corruption
où en sont ces manifestations
aujourd'hui on s'est beaucoup de jeunes
quittent le pays
oui beaucoup de jeunes aujourd'hui qui
quittent le pays parce que en fait les
ils sentent qu'il n'y a plus vraiment
d'espoir maintenant il est très
important de d'essayer de recréer cet
espoir et pour recréer cet espoir il
faut que justement l'argent
internationale viennent dans le pays
pour pouvoir relancer l'économie
aujourd'hui la jeunesse a quand même
porté au devant des idées importantes
par exemple là l'idée d'une certaine
laïcisation avec la demande
d'unification du statut personnel dans
le code civil c'est-à-dire le mariage
civil entre autres c'est mais il ya
cette demande mais il ya également
d'autres il ya des réformes importantes
à faire par exemple la loi une loi sur
l'indépendance de la justice pour
pouvoir juger
justement les politiciens s'il le faut
et nous d'autant qu'il ya un audit
juricomptable qui a été lancé il faut
également lancé les dossiers de
décentralisation qui sont prévues
constitutionnellement mais aussi le
dossier de la neutralité positive
permanente et reconnues
internationalement qui est porté
aujourd'hui par le patriarche maronite
il est très important d'avancer sur tous
ces dossiers pour pouvoir en fait donner
un nouveau souffle au liban un autre
dossier bien sûr c'est la
décentralisation parce que la
décentralisation en fête permettra à ce
que des projets puissent se réaliser
localement que les citoyens puisse les
contrôler et donc en fait donner du
souffle à l'économie libanaise
merci beaucoup michel faial d'avoir
répondu à nos questions ce soir sur arte
france
allez on fait le point sur la situation
sanitaire en france à présent près de 17
mille nouveaux cas de covile recensés
ces dernières 24 heures un taux de
positivité à 7,9 pour 149 décès
supplémentaires pour un total de 32 1198
morts dans le pays depuis le début de
cette pandémie
paris et la proche banlieue qui pourrait
basculer dans les prochaines heures en
zone d' alerte maximale
conséquence les bars pourrait fermer
cette semaine les professionnels ont
tenté de tout faire pour améliorer les
protocoles sanitaires afin d'échapper au
même sort qu'à marseille rania berrada
après la fermeture totale est très
contestée des restaurants et des bars à
marseille les restaurateurs et les
hôteliers sont arrivés remonter à
matignon ce mardi au menu des
discussions avec le premier ministre et
le ministre de l'économie les nouvelles
mesures restrictives pour faire face au
rebond épidémique une grogne que
l'exécutif a tenté d'atténuer en faisant
d'eux annonce d'une part la prolongation
du chômage partiel à 100 % jusqu'au 31
décembre dans les bars et restaurants
d'autre part un fonds de solidarité
désormais fixé à dix mille euros contre
1500 jusqu'à présent des annonces
d'accompagnement bienvenu mais il est
plus important que les établissements
restent ouverts selon les organisations
professionnelles reçu à matignon on peut
plus fermer des entreprises
on peut plus fermer des entreprises
qu'est ce que demandent nos nono
caffuccino restaurateurs nos hôteliers
c'est simple ils veulent travailler
alors derrière bien sûr il ya des
mesures d'accompagnement qui sont très
importantes
mais le premier point qu'ils veulent
c'est travailler donc est trouvé dans
liberty comprennent le plaquant les a
montrés du doigt comme ça sur des sujets
comme ça parce qu'elle est très
important pour nous c'est d'arrêter de
stigmatiser une profession qui a
démontré depuis maintenant plusieurs
mois que nous étions ouverts connections
j'avais des clients que nous avons
impliqué appliquée protocole comme l'ont
fait tous les efforts pour protéger et
nos salariés et nos clients et donc nous
sommes en rien responsables aujourd'hui
bien au contraire nous voulons aider le
gouvernement tout en restant ouvert et
donc pour notre métier ouvert pas sûr
que les restaurants parisiens le reste
dans les prochains jours jeudi lors d'un
point presse olivier ferrand a fait part
de son inquiétude au sujet des chiffres
relevés dans la capitale et qui pourrait
la faire passer d
ce lundi en zone d' alerte maximale la
situation de la métropole parisienne
maintenant où là aussi vous voyez qu'il
ya une dégradation qui s'est accélérée
sur paris et la petite couronne depuis
hier en effet dans les dernières 24
heures
paris a franchi les trois seuils qui
peuvent correspondre à la zone dite d'
alerte maximale
ce franchissement des seuils nous
l'observons que depuis quelques heures
nous avons besoin évidemment de le
confirmer dans les tout prochains jours
mais si ça devait se confirmer nous
n'aurions pas d'autre choix que de
placer paris et la petite couronne en
zone d' alerte maximale et ce dès lundi
si tel devait être le cas les
restaurateurs parisiens et leurs voisins
de petit couronne pourrait connaître le
même sort que leurs confrères provençaux
une fermeture complète que les gérants
d'établissements redoute évidemment
plusieurs d'entre eux ont manifesté ce
vendredi apa c'est important parce qu'en
ce moment le métier très dur avec tout
ce qui s'est passé et tout ce qui se
passe en ce moment on a vraiment du mal
du mal à à brax suivre le cours le cours
de la vie est ce que ça représente
vraiment aujourd'hui ben c'est l'union
de tous les restaurateurs du personnel
aussi de la restauration et pour dire
qu'on est tous les ensembles et qu'on se
battra jusqu'au bout pour que on est au
moins le droit de de faire notre métier
correctement lors de son point presse le
ministre de la santé avait tout de même
laissé entendre qu'une autre solution
que la fermeture était en élaboration
dans un dispositif où les restaurateurs
appliquerez des protocoles sanitaires
renforcés de nouvelles normes que le
gouvernement devrait dévoiler dans les
prochains jours et c'est la fin de ce
journal merci de votre fidélité on se
retrouve dans 30 minutes reste avec nous
[Musique]
14 juillet 2015 et signe à vienne un
accord de limitation du nucléaire
iranien à sa partie purement civil
contrairement aux engagements de
l'accord signé et